he got five minutes before six on your
Wednesday morning have you made your
weekend plans where we got Nate out of
the town to help out the San Gennaro
Feast gets underway today down at the M
Resort you know about the music the
games carnival rides and obviously the
Italian food 15 bucks to get in they do
charge extra at the different food
booths it runs through Sunday and
speaking of Sunday they're going to have
a fireworks show at San Gennaro in honor
of Mother's Day on Sunday now speaking
of Mother's Day maybe you want to take
Mom to the Art Festival down in
Henderson it's actually both Saturday
and Sunday 9 A.M to 4 P.M beautiful
downtown Water Street a hundred
different artist Booth vendors they're
doing art performances like glass
blowing which is really cool to see in
person even a chalk art gallery
how about Saturday night a free outdoor
movie showing it's top gun Maverick this
is at the district at Green Valley Ranch
down in the Southeast Valley they'll let
you grab a seat there at 7 00 PM the
movie starts whenever the sun goes down
don't worry if you miss this one because
every Saturday in both May and June
they're showing different movies down
there at the district at Green Valley
Ranch you know how you get there of
course is you take the highway to the
danger zone to see Top Gun I see such a
good movie go see it if you haven't seen
it